- So wait, what's the worst
vacation you've been on?
- Oh, God.
Yeah, I have some terrible ones of those.
- You do?
- Yeah, I think the worst one I got,
I was, you know, in my mid-twenties
and I was backpacking around,
and my sandals that I had
kind of disintegrated, but
I wanted to be barefoot.
I thought I was kinda a
real hardcore traveler.
Anyway, I picked something up in my foot,
which was a small parasitic worm.
And months later, it
takes a while to just,
you know, just stay.
And months later, I felt these track marks
coming up my ankle.
(squeals)
- [Kelly] Oh no, oh no.
- They would blister, and I wasn't sure
what it was, so I went to the doctors.
You know, the local doctor,
they didn't know what it was.
I went into London to the
tropical medicine department,
they didn't know what it was.
- Are they in your skin?
- They're in my skin.
- Oh God, Oh God, Oh God, Oh God.
- Yeah.
- Wait, that's so gross.
- And in the day, they're dormant, right?
But at night is when they're active.
So you'd be asleep, and then you'd wake up
and you'd feel something
tracking up your leg, literally.
I remember running down and
going and getting some cutlery
and being like, "Yeah,
yeah," trying to cut it out.
But, you know, you can't just cut it out.
You have to take drugs for it.
- Oh my God. Oh, I would be so drugged up.
(audience and guests laugh)